um so my segment is going to be really
short really really short uh and the the
the the title here is what is the
healthiest diet
um so I was getting into this a little
bit because
um I was doing a piece for Mass about
just kind of painting with broad Strokes
about nutrition like it if you were just
to give someone a really simple set of
guidelines and say you know what this is
gonna broadly nudge you in the direction
of a healthy eating pattern is this
perfect have we fully solved human
nutrition and optimized it for
performance and Longevity not quite
we're not there you know but we have
learned a couple things and I think it's
important to when possible lean on the
things that we have some decent evidence
for right so
um I was putting together this piece
about like what are some of those
guidelines that can broadly set us in
the right direction with our eating
patterns
um so that's one reason I wanted to talk
about this the other reason is I don't
think it's happening more or changing
all that much but I feel like in recent
months I've been so much more aware of
the arguments on social media of just
like the wars between all these
different popular diets and everyone's
so focused on identifying the one and
only optimal diet for the entirety of
humanity uh that is perfect in all ways
not just in some ways but actually my
way of dieting is best for your brain
your performance your body comp your
long-term Health longevity cardio
metabolic Health even the environment
all of the things are best with my diet
uh and when you see when you see people
making those those
same sets of claims for two diets that
are literally mutually exclusive you're
like what the hell is going on here guys
yeah
um so it's it's harder than that let me
let me note up top as as both your
friend and business partner I am uh both
delighted and terrified by this by this
recent development of you becoming aware
of these things because I remember I
remember back when we met and you were
in grad school and we would talk about
just like Fitness industry stuff you had
a pretty good knowledge of everything
that had been going on before you went
to grad school and then things that had
happened within the last like four or
five years very murky you were a bit
busy guy in the lab all the time barely
on social media not really monitoring
the chatter and now you've you've been
out of grad school enough and worked in
a business that has to be on social
media for for things to function enough
that over the last two or three years
you you've you've started to become
sucked into the Vortex of just the the
dumbest and most ridiculous but also
most entertaining online arguments about
inane [ __ ] related to Health Nutrition
Fitness and uh I'm so excited for what
what the future holds as you continue to
descend down those rabbit holes yeah I
mean so like for context here you know
my brain didn't fully come online
especially in the nutrition world you
know until like the late 2000s which
would have put me in my late teens
basically
um I think that's right yeah so I mean
you know all the stuff that was going on
in the 70s and 80s perhaps it was as
vitriolic and just flatly insane as it
is today I doubt it
um but but yeah then so I was kind of
tapped in in the like late 2000s early
2010s then I went to grad school and
everything happening in the outside
world was just silenced I was just kind
of stuck in the lab uh physically and
mentally and yeah I I've emerged and I'm
just like what in the world's going on
and I will admit I've been clicking on
more things lately yeah and so now all
of the algorithm focused social media
sites are like oh you like really dumb
claims about nutrition
guess what I have a million of them and
they're just flooding into my feed so I
I do think I like I said over the last
couple months but
it's really been over the last few years
but over the last couple months I've
been clicking stuff yeah and and I'm
really seeing the full wake of
algorithmic social media uh and news
feed stuff it's good stuff yeah my news
feeds and timelines and all that stuff
are just getting insane like I'm losing
touch with reality from some of the
stuff I'm seeing uh it's just uh a
dazzling array of just insane claims and
and exaggerations and just flat out
misinformation uh about nutrition so
anyway uh you know like I I feel like
back in the day it wasn't quite like
this where there was like some general
agreement on you know
broadly speaking what a decent diet
looked like yeah and then they were you
know they're of course quibbling over
the details and then maybe uh following
some lines of research that eventually
fell flat you know for a minute there
everyone's like oh this this margarine
stuff seems pretty great we can make
these these trans fatty acids that seems
like a good idea and then eventually
they're like ah yeah about the trans
fatty acids maybe maybe not yeah you
know so um
anyway these days things have gotten
wild and and one of the things that um
really jumps out to me is that
science is incremental and it's slow
it's slow and it's incremental every now
and then you'll have a paradigm shift
that will really fundamentally change
the trajectory of that boring slow kind
of incremental progress
but in the nutrition space right now
everyone is fully committed it seems to
just imploding the Paradigm like I I
can't tell you the number of pitches for
a fringe diet that they they all start
with okay first of all forget everything
you thought you knew about nutrition and
it's like but I don't want to like yeah
I don't think it's a good idea for that
to be the starting point for all
nutritional discourse is forget
everything you believe you you know yeah
I mean if you fully subscribe to the
current scientific consensus really on
any topic but like nutrition included uh
you will probably take on
five percent incorrect beliefs just
because yeah science doesn't know
everything yet uh things are provisional
um and yeah like the The History of
Science suggests that we've been wrong
about plenty of things before and I'm
sure we're we're wrong about plenty of
things right now but
what percentage of our current
scientific understanding of nutrition is
wrong I feel like it's a number less
than a hundred percent so someone's
saying throw out everything there are a
lot of babies being tossed out with that
bath water yeah it kind of feels like if
you were slowly and methodically over
about eight decades working your way
toward the center of a maze and then uh
on a whim you just said
can you take me back to the start I I
just want to start fresh and see what
happens right and it's like you can look
at it from above and be like dude you
were pretty close like you were really
you were really getting there yeah
before you said hey on a whim I'll start
over and try my luck with a different
path yeah so yeah there's there's this
knee-jerk reaction of just forget
everything that people have forget all
the knowledge that has has been obtained
over the last hundred years and let's
just like go on Vibes or you know
strained theories and dude I was telling
you off air I saw a thing you know
people look at these univariate
correlations okay let's forget
everything else in the world exists and
only look at two variables right and you
know you'll see this all the time you'll
say oh well look at saturated fat
increase his uh intake has increased
since the 80s and look at this
cardiometabolic or obesity rates you
know it looks like they were both going
up at the same time I'm not good or you
know hey look at sugar intake over the
last 30 years and obesity rates looks
like they're both going up
dude I saw one the other day that was
looking at you know again with a
univariate correlation like this it's
basically saying okay let's just assume
everything else is equal
no other major confounders that we
really have to worry about here
uh pretty smooth sailing but we'll just
look at these two variables some
nutritional variable and obesity rates
the x-axis started in the 17 I think it
started at the year 1700 and it was
looking at sugar intake in the UK love
that and like you were saying off air
it's like if you're going to look at a
temporal correlation with obesity
just like any instance of
industrialization is going to correlate
with obesity over that time scale yeah
like like virtually anything like so
yeah there's just so many uh insanely
off track posts that you can run into
that's kind of why I wanted to do a
little segment on like so what if we
didn't forget everything we know and
instead just kind of made a short list
of the things that we feel pretty good
about knowing so that's really the
direction here so you know there's all
these diets to pick from
and people that will defend them to the
death uh you know high carb high fat
carnivore vegan Mediterranean the list
goes on and on and on there's there's
these diets that people want to fight
over and always the question underlying
those those conversations is what is the
best diet and I feel very strongly that
that is the wrong question to be asking
I would throw that question out entirely
and I would start from a different
perspective and that is first of all
what are the the major health issues
that appear to be uh quite meaningfully
impacted by dietary habits you know what
are the most pressing health issues that
seem to be very closely linked to
dietary habits and behaviors and and to
me some of the ones that really come up
are obesity diabetes hypertension heart
disease and cancer those are some of the
things that come to mind for me and so
then the second question you ask ask
yourself instead of what is the best
diet for all things you kind of key in
on those if we're focused on health
right so we'll kind of put performance
and stuff aside so we've got this kind
of cluster of uh you know pathologies or
characteristics or whatever these things
that seem to be correlated with uh
negative cardiometabolic Health outcomes
or just generally you know mortality
rates and other health outcomes
we've got this set of things we're
focused on instead of asking what is the
best diet for all things what kind of
dietary patterns
patterns not diets seem to reduce or
Elevate risks for these independent
outcomes right and so when we look at
for example obesity rates you know and
we say well what kind of dietary factors
or patterns seem to be uh important to
consider here you might look at a diet
and say okay well what kind of energy
density are we talking about uh in what
way is this diet uh supporting satiety
you know satiety and hunger regulation
uh what how many hyper palatable foods
are finding their way into this diet
what we're looking at is dietary
patterns that generally promote uh the
over consumption of total energy you
know so the term you'll see in the
literature sometimes is over nutrition
just what kind of things within a
dietary pattern nudge us toward over
consumption and a lot of times it does
come back to those factors energy
density satiety regulation and Hyper
palatability uh with diabetes that was
one of the ones I mentioned
um you know of course over nutrition or
over consumption of energy is certainly
a factor so we would lean on those
previous factors I mentioned there those
previous uh broad dietary patterns
um and other things that come up though
with diabetes is we might specifically
look at to what extent are we kind of
acutely overloading the liver with uh
excess energy substrates not acutely it
like meal to meal day to day but are we
having extended periods of time where we
are coupling over nutrition with over
consumption of maybe some key nutrients
that really promote uh the accretion of
fat within the liver itself because I
think a lot of people under appreciate
the role that the liver plays when it
comes to glucose homeostasis but uh the
glue the liver influences many many
different Pathways that are very
critical in glycemic control and so if
you're over feeding and you have low
physical activity those two things alone
are the key drivers and I don't want to
lose sight of that
um but you might also take it a step
further and say well aside from those
two main drivers we might also be a
little bit wary about dietary patterns
that promote really high intakes of
specific nutrients that uh
disproportionately facilitate fat
accretion in the liver and the two that
come to mind would be saturated fat and
fructose that doesn't mean that you need
to restrict both of those to the
greatest extent possible but what it
means is you know if we want to limit
risk for type 2 diabetes we want to
avoid over nutrition and low physical
activity those are by far the most
important drivers but we can also look
at some individual like if you're really
going heavy on the saturated fat and the
fructose especially from added sugars in
combination with over nutrition and low
activity those are the types of patterns
that we might want to keep our eye on
yeah with hypertension broadly in many
cases we're going to be looking at
sodium potassium and some key
phytonutrients that can affect in
vascular and endothelial function heart
disease you know we might be looking at
specific fatty acid intakes added sugar
intake fiber intake and then with cancer
we're looking in many cases at
intake of fiber certain phytonutrients
that that might decrease cancer risk and
then of course carcinogenic compounds
that find their way directly into the
diet things that that seem to have
pretty direct links to the promotion of
cancer formation so uh of course these
are hard to separate entirely you know
because a lot of these fall under the
umbrella of metabolic syndrome and so
over nutrition and low activity is kind
of broadly influencing essentially all
of these outcomes but we can start to
look into little kind of individual
nuances for each outcome and again kind
of ask ourselves not just the name of a
diet that works here uh but but broadly
speaking what kind of dietary guidelines
and patterns might we be nudged toward
if we were really focusing on minimizing
risk here and this Probably sounds like
it's going to be like a three hour
segment where we go a deep dive into
each individual
um outcome but instead I want to lean on
a couple sets of guidelines that I've uh
been looking over lately that I think
provide a pretty sensible starting point
now
the huge caveat that's going to carry a
lot of weight here uh I'm gonna go over
these guidelines there's two different
tables that have a high degree of
overlap
I'm not saying that any diet that
deviates from one of these guidelines is
a seriously and severely flawed diet
that's not what I'm doing here I'm not
saying that when we put these together
we have the perfect human diet frankly
I've given up on the idea of a singular
perfect human diet humans are pretty
flexible pretty adaptable that's why
we're still here uh throughout all of
the famines in our evolutionary history
we can adapt to a lot and live on a lot
of different diets so you know sometimes
you'll you'll hear people say oh you
know this isn't technically an essential
nutrient therefore you should never eat
it and if you do eat it it's bad for you
that that's silly you know humans there
are some essential nutrients we need but
to discredit a dietary pattern because
it includes like carbohydrates that are
not technically considered an essential
nutrient it's nonsense it truly doesn't
make any sense so what I'm going to to
talk about here are some guidelines I do
think it's funny that that
same logic like if that's what you're
saying like if something isn't necessary
you don't need to consume it at all
I've never seen someone apply that same
logic to non-essential amino acids yeah
but like why shouldn't it apply you know
yeah no it it's
um it's a convenient way to discredit a
dietary pattern that includes something
that yours does not yeah it's it's the
type of thing where if you throw it out
to an audience that doesn't really have
their guard their guards up it's sound
it sounds really uh
insightful and impressive until you
think about it for three seconds yeah
and then hopefully you have continued
talking enough that people won't think
about it for three seconds because
they're thinking about the next thing
yeah exactly so what I'm going to talk
about here is uh a couple sets of
dietary guidelines that
again it's it's kind of a la carte you
know cafeteria style when I'm putting
together a dietary pattern and
establishing eating behaviors and habits
what I want to try to do is check some
of these boxes off so this is not a
concise list that leads you toward a
particular named diet this is just
things that like ah it would be nice if
your diet checks a lot of these boxes or
it you know we shouldn't really treat
them as dichotomous either so if for
example you're supposed to get 400 grams
a day of something and it's like okay
well I usually get about
320 well that's better than 100 right so
it's about these are some guidelines to
shoot for you want to get close to them
if you can and ideally get close to many
of them you know and check off as many
of these boxes as you can so
table number one that I'm looking at
here I'll put it on the screen these are
the healthy diet indicator criteria uh
from the World Health Organization uh
and I know uh some people
the World Health Organization isn't
necessarily your direct Pathway to make
people say okay now I can let my guard
down I know a lot of people have said a
lot of things about the the who in
recent years uh their Q rating I guess
isn't as high as it used to be uh a q
rating is like a term that they'll use
in like uh various places like how do
people generally view you like your
general Good Vibes uh to to an audience
yeah yeah so yeah people have been uh
really critical of the World Health
Organization and in some very
specific pockets of the population I'd
say yeah for uh
I would say for a combination of of
deserved and undeserved reasons and I
don't want to elaborate beyond that yeah
so what I want to get at here is
regardless of the organization you don't
want to just say well I'm going to turn
off critical thinking and just because
any particular organization says
something yeah I'm not gonna you know
I'm just gonna blindly accept all of it
but in this case uh it's a set of
criteria that is extremely compatible
with the best available evidence and
nutrition it's a really rigorous set of
criteria that I think uh leads you
toward a really nice eating pattern and
for the record I have I currently have a
high level of trust for the World Health
Organization I I think they're doing
their best and generally doing a decent
job but anyway uh table one here uh
fruits and vegetables you want to be
aiming for over greater than or equal to
400 grams a day total fat you want to
limit that to no more than 30 percent of
total energy saturated fat no more than
10 percent of total energy
polyunsaturated fats aiming for six to
eleven percent of total energy uh free
sugar or like added sugars less than 10
percent of total energy dietary fiber at
least 25 grams a day
and potassium at least 3 500 milligrams
per day
now people are going to look at that uh
in a variety of different diet
um
groups you know people who are kind of
really strong proponents of a particular
diet there's going to be some elements
they love in some elements they hate so
for example if you're someone who's
really um really adamant about ketogenic
diets you would look at total fat less
than 30 percent of total energy you're
not gonna like that I'm gonna be pretty
annoyed by that but you might look at
free you know added sugar less than 10
of total energy and say well yeah that
that makes sense that's sensible
um so it's important to recognize I'm
not saying that like no one can be
healthy on a ketogenic diet right but
but this is kind of a list of just
painting with broad Strokes what general
dietary patterns seem to be associated
with really positive outcomes in terms
of mortality and just broadly cardio
metabolic Health uh so that's the first
table the second table that was from
2015. that was the the set of criteria
uh looking at 2020
there's an updated set of criteria I
can't really tell based on the paper if
this is necessarily like from the World
Health Organization or if it's just a
research group who said I we want to
propose some 2020 updates to it but in
any case I I do think it adds a couple
little boxes to it that that are that
are pretty sensible so
um the the scoring for for these three
things is just greater than zero grams
per day which just means hey try to eat
this stuff yeah it's generally
associated with some nice things uh and
those categories are beans and other
legumes uh nuts and seeds and whole
grains and broadly speaking when you
look at the observational literature and
you combine it with randomized
controlled trials uh dietary patterns
that feature these uh in you know
relatively moderate to to high amounts
seem to seem to do pretty well right so
that's why the the uh the recommendation
is greater than zero grams it's like try
to build a diet that includes some of
these things it recommends limiting
limiting dietary sodium to less than two
grams a day so less than 2 000
milligrams it recommends zero grams per
day of processed meat
which qualitatively Speaking just means
um probably don't eat processed meat if
you do you know try to limit that to the
extent you can and then for unprocessed
meat it says less than 71 less than or
equal to 71 grams a day very oddly
specific number but but what they're
generally getting at there is hey you
know there's there's other protein
sources that are not neces or no I said
unprocessed meat it should be
unprocessed red meat yeah so that that's
actually a big flub that I made there so
they're referring specifically to
unprocessed red meat with that limit of
less than or equal to 71 grams per day
so again broadly speaking what they're
doing is looking at the literature in
aggregate in its totality and saying
okay these seem like generally good
boxes to check when you're putting
together a relatively healthy eating
pattern
um and again we don't want to approach
this super dogmatically right so for
example with sodium
that's going to be one that gets people
pretty riled up because right now
there's a pretty big contingent
especially in the fitness space saying
like you know what your biggest problem
is you're not having enough sodium and
you need to have salt like before your
workouts and stuff
um and then there's another contingent
that's kind of more from the
conventional Health literature saying it
seems like you know in populations where
there's really high sodium intake
hypertension seems to be a prevalent
issue and for a large percentage of
those folks reducing sodium and or
increasing potassium seems to very much
help with those hypertension outcomes so
with sodium it gets complicated because
there does seem to be a some diversity
in terms of genotype where some people
are more sensitive to Salt than others
when it comes to blood pressure and
hypertension so some people will
increase their dietary sodium and it
really doesn't affect their blood
pressure much at all some people
increase their dietary sodium and their
blood pressure goes up and they might
have higher risk for hypertension and
there are even some people who uh they
almost have like an inverse relationship
where if they are at their normal level
and they drastically minimize their
sodium intake their blood pressure
actually goes up uh which is which is a
bit odd
um and so I I don't think it's
easy to do like a one-size-fits-all
recommendation for sodium and then of
course I mean you start talking about
athletes who compete in or or train
train and compete in hot weather and you
know they're losing a lot of sodium in
their sweat so their sodium needs are
kind of influenced by that so again
we're not not putting these guidelines
on a pedestal and being super dogmatic
and saying you need to check every
single box regardless of context but you
know like I was getting at earlier I
think when it comes to putting together
a healthy dietary pattern we want to
just kind of lean on what seems to be
the consensus of the best available
evidence like what things do we have a
pretty good handle on currently when we
look at long-term cardiometabolic
outcomes and mortality outcomes and when
we kind of put these two tables together
we start to get a really nice set of
dietary criteria that we can broadly
view as compatible with favorable Health
outcomes to what extent you wish to
adhere to any particular one of these is
totally up to you like I'm not here to
get in an argument with someone who says
well I like to eat way more than 30
percent of my calories from fat that's
totally fine what I would say to that
person
and a lot of people are in that position
ketogenic diet does have some very
sensible applications
um but what I would say is okay you want
to have 70 percent of your calories
coming from fat that falls short of one
of these boxes
um but where's that fat coming from you
know maybe maybe then you say okay but
you know I am limiting added sugar I am
eating plenty of uh you know
very fibrous low starch vegetables so
that I'm getting fiber in I'm getting my
vegetables every day uh through that
maybe I'm getting plenty of potassium my
fiber is adequate you know what what I
would encourage people to do is not say
there's one Criterion on this list that
I hate therefore I'm throwing out
everything yeah you know the purpose of
this you know you might say I I don't
really like beans and legumes fine but
you you can still you know adhere to or
or strive to meet some of these other uh
quantitative objectives and it will
probably be fairly compatible with some
nice Health outcomes you know so you
don't have to to buy the whole list or
sell the whole list but it is a set of
criteria that broadly nudge people
towards some pretty uh pretty Health
compatible eating patterns so broadly
speaking what we're looking at here when
you start to just condense it more
qualitatively is plenty of fiber which
broadly speaking seems to be a really
solid thing for for a variety of Health
outcomes
what I would call a suit a suitable
intake of both potassium and sodium and
this is one of those things if you're
like listen I don't think I'm
particularly sensitive to sodium in the
diet I don't want to worry that much
about potassium and sodium you know
either their absolute amounts or their
relative amounts compared to one another
for those folks I'd say at bare minimum
just keep an eye on your blood pressure
you know if you start noticing that
you're getting into the pre-hypertension
or even hypertension range of course I'm
not a doctor you know so this isn't
medical advice but if I started to see
my blood pressure going up I'd go and
chat with a doctor and say what's going
on here and they might say hey why don't
you try limiting sodium and see what
happens you know there might be a
variety of different routes you can take
there so if you're someone who doesn't
want to get really particular about
potassium and sodium I totally get that
I know a lot of natural bodybuilders who
they're like hey I just noticed that I
eat seven grams of sodium per day is
that bad and that's kind of high but I
mean you know their blood pressure is in
a normal range they're they're not
having any adverse cardio metabolic
indices that can really be observed and
they're keeping an eye on those things
and it's like well then I don't know do
what you want to do yeah that that's
kind of the boat I'm in I I'm it uh
probably yeah probably like six seven
grams of sodium a day yeah like you're
like you're describing
um the issue I have if anything is
getting hypotensive
um and even even when I was up near 280
uh blood pressure was like 110 over 70
and it's it's lower now which is
unfortunate yeah um that's crazy that's
really low sometimes stand up and ooh
get all woozy but yeah but yeah so uh
but yeah if I was it
if my blood pressure was like 140 over
90 or something
um then I certainly would cut back yeah
or at least you know get with a doctor
and say what do you what do you
recommend as a first line of action here
and I I expect they probably would say
let's look at probably sodium if not
both sodium and potassium and just try
to get those in a more
more uh comfortable balance based on
what your blood pressure is telling you
yeah
um so yeah the broad Strokes here high
fiber a suitable potassium to sodium
intake
um usually blood pressure is going to
help you kind of figure out if that
needs to be acted upon plenty of fruits
and vegetables you want to minimize
processed meats and charred meats you
know you don't uh eating charred meat
that um
you know there have been some studies
saying yeah maybe not ideal for gastric
cancers
um red meat in moderation you know I'm
certainly not saying that you know
people should eat zero red meat but
broadly speaking when you look at the at
the literature It generally tends and it
Trends in the direction of of saying uh
maybe in moderation you know
uh the the long-term Health outcome
literature for example for like fish and
poultry seems to be a little bit more
favorable than it is for red meat
especially fatty cuts of red meat
um you want to eat enough protein to
support lean body mass of course which
doesn't necessarily take all that much
as we've talked about previously
um uh maintaining a reasonably High
ratio of polyunsaturated to saturated
fatty acids seems to do pretty well in
the literature I know a lot of people uh
have essentially built their entire
personality around uh fighting that
recommendation like if you were to go
out and say hey like polyunsaturated
fats pretty good saturated fat might
want to limit some people will just
absolutely lose it when that comes up
but
I mean the literature isn't really that
hard to parse with those outcomes it it
looks pretty pretty straightforward like
I wouldn't say like yeah I mean there
there have been both observational uh
lines of evidence and randomized
controlled trials where managing that
ratio of polyunsaturated a saturated
fatty acid preferably nudging it toward
the higher range seems to be pretty good
for blood lipids and cardio metabolic
outcomes uh total fat intake you know
not too low not too high that that's
where a lot of the research generally
nudges you toward and then saturated
fatty acaturated fatty acids capping
those at less than 10 percent of total
energy broadly speaking seems to be
pretty compatible with with the research
um you have something to say I I do just
just one one thing to point out that I
find kind of funny
um so you you mentioned uh people who
who just like really push back against
the polyunsaturated to saturated fat uh
stuff and also just just people in
general who have uh Fringe nutrition
ideas that are very much not supported
by by the literature
um like one thing to note uh that I I
think most listeners are probably aware
of is that a lot of the research in
nutrition
um specifically for longer for long-term
Health outcomes comes from either like
either like observational
epidemiological studies or like cohort
studies there aren't you know there
aren't that many like 30 40 year rcts
where you say
I don't know if they're any but yeah
like it's not like there are a ton of
studies where you say like Hey we're
gonna we're gonna have one group eat low
saturated fat one group eat High
saturated fat for the next 30 years and
just observe the outcomes and like
they're definitely going to stick to
that
um because yeah like that's that's not
how how humans eat
um like people aren't going to want to
sign up for a study where researchers
are controlling their diet for the next
three decades so uh people with with
very heterodox uh nutritional ideas will
point to the research that does exist
and be like oh you're making the classic
blunder
um you're drawing causal inferences from
observational research uh which that
part in in a vacuum is is a fair
critique and then they'll take the next
step and say and in fact
these things that healthy people seem to
do
it is actually bad for their health but
because people are telling them they're
healthy like they're doing these things
but also like a lot of other healthy
behaviors and so ultimately you're
dealing with with a case of healthy user
bias where it looks like the things I'm
promoting are associated with bad Health
outcomes looks like the things uh the
World Health Organization uh
uh like the EU similar body like similar
body in the US like it seems like all of
the things they're promoting are
associated with good health outcomes but
you know what turns out you can't
believe any of that stuff because it's
all just observational research and uh
actually you should just only live on a
diet of raw red meat yeah but the the
thing is
then they'll they'll come back with
claims of like and guess what carbs
they'll kill you uh all seed oils and
things with uh high levels of omega-6s
they're poison they'll kill you
vegetables guess what they'll also kill
you but it's like
I have a hard time understanding how you
square that with the critique of
observational research and healthy user
bias because the thing is if those
things are so bad
you still have to contend with the fact
that the folks who do who eat that way
still do have generally positive Health
outcomes like right there there is an
upward constraint on how bad and
poisonous those things can be you know
yeah unless you're contending that like
if those people were just eating the way
I told them they would live to maybe 150
years old yeah you know like yeah it is
so someone tried to like drag me into a
debate uh which is always the best way
to do it uh just a online debate we're
two very confident people yell over each
other and cannot fact check each other
in real time that's always the best uh
someone said hey you should debate this
person and I said like we have such um
severe
gaps uh such a mismatch
in terms of the way we view epistemology
just what levels of evidence we find to
be convincing and compelling and like we
we can't even agree on like broadly
speaking what is the hierarchy of
evidence for nutrition and what counts
as very credible nutrition evidence and
based on that there would be no utility
of doing a debate uh and and it was it's
kind of like hey let's play this sport
um but we absolutely will not agree upon
the rules before the match yeah we'll
just go into it you'll be playing one
sport I'll be playing a fully different
version
and we'll just like kind of figure out
how it went after the fact yeah
um but yeah I mean there there's so many
instances where you'll see people saying
yeah I mean sure there's all this
evidence that that shows that at bare
minimum all these things are are really
really compatible with with great health
and and you know excellent long-term
Health outcomes
um but I want to throw that out because
have you seen this in vitro research you
know or I eat very differently and sure
enough I am right here and alive so how
do you explain that yeah um yeah there's
just like there's just this General
rejection of you know really high
quality epidemiological research and
nutrition
um
rejection you know well the rcts are too
short the the epidemiological stuff is
too observational the cohort stuff they
didn't really control it that well even
though it was a you know a cohort based
intervention over several decades so
like let's just bring it back to the
petri dishes and just assume that I can
learn more from a mouse with
fundamentally different metabolic
characteristics than I can from 20 000
humans who were involved in a a
prospective cohort intervention yeah um
I don't know what to do with that so
like I'm certain that they're going to
be a lot of folks that hear this segment
and say uh this Trexler guy is an idiot
because has he seen this mouse study and
ignored all the relevant human evidence
and yeah there's some of these battles
that just really can't be won in the
short term and uh
it is what it is but uh now that we've
discussed some of these broad Strokes
um
kind of basic eating patterns and kind
of guidelines that seem to be most
compatible with the current evidence
inevitably people are going to say yeah
but give me a diet give me a named diet
that works and is better than the rest
I don't want to do that but I will say
there there are multiple named diets
that generally check off
uh plenty of these boxes right so a
couple that come to mind this isn't the
whole list but two that come to mind I
think the DASH diet tends to be a pretty
sensible diet I think if you don't have
hypertension there might be some
constraints in there that are not fully
applicable to you
um so I'm not saying it's the perfect
diet for all people but the DASH diet
tends to do pretty well uh the
Mediterranean diet tends to do pretty
well I know a lot of people then come in
and argue very aggressively about what
the Mediterranean diet truly is
um I'm just going off of the
intervention studies and the set of
characteristics that have broadly been
embraced in the literature to this point
so for example uh stuff you eat on the
Mediterranean diet plenty of whole
grains legumes fruits vegetables healthy
fats herbs and spices I read that quote
from uh an image here before people just
absolutely tear me apart for using the
term healthy fats but broadly speak
they're talking about fats that have a
lot of unsaturated fatty acids and
relatively low saturated fatty acid
content the stuff that is you know still
pretty heavily emphasized but not quite
as much as the others we've got fish
other seafood and foods that are rich in
omega-3 fatty acids uh poultry eggs and
dairy still part of the diet but not not
quite as as highly emphasized and then
things that you would eat sparingly
would be things like red meats and you
know sweets with a lot of added sugar
when we look at the DASH diet again
plenty of vegetables fruits whole grains
low low-ish fat dairy products fish
poultry beans nuts seeds vegetable oil
stuff like that things that you would
limit on a dash diet or that kind of
eating pattern would be fatty Meats full
fat Dairy sugar sweetened beverages
sweets and you know really high added
sodium intake
um you know people again are gonna go
nuts and say well here's this study on
full fat Dairy that says it's fine I'm
not saying that these eating patterns
are I'm not saying that every guideline
in here is fully necessary for every
single individual but these are a couple
dietary patterns that bra broadly
speaking are pretty compatible with
those broad guidelines from the two uh
the two healthy diet indicator sets of
criteria that I mentioned previously
yeah just saying like if if you're very
insistent about having a named diet yeah
these these seem to be pretty good yeah
they seem to be pretty good but most
importantly the the key Point here is
that these are not the only two options
there are plenty of Cuisines around the
world that are very much compatible with
these broad sets of eating patterns and
eating behaviors so like I know one
thing a lot of people say is that some
of these um
some of these named diets often tend to
be used in a way that
kind of excludes major portions of the
world you know it just kind of
recommends like particular food items
and like you know sometimes you'll see
like here's a sample meal pattern and
you'll find that it is it's very
um
it's not very compat compatible with
different Cuisines around the world uh
and just you know different
um you know spices and food sources you
know they tend to get very regionalized
and say okay everyone in the world
ignore your cultural traditions and eat
just this set of foods right and that's
not necessary there's plenty of Cuisines
around the entire world that could be
fully compatible with these types of of
eating patterns uh with you know just
little modifications and little bits of
effort here and there to incorporate
certain food items so um yeah I'm not
saying you know everyone has to eat
these two name diets these are two that
come to mind that are pretty well
studied that check a lot of the boxes
but I mean I've been eating a lot of
different uh
you know as I've kind of transitioned
into a more plant-based eating pattern
I've been eating a lot more Asian
Cuisines I've been eating a lot of
Chinese food thai food Vietnamese food
Indian food
um and yeah man it's great but but it is
kind of kind of eye-opening I used to I
used to eat essentially just shredded
chicken for every meal and like just nor
just eating like kind of the the very
generic sets of vegetables that come in
the American supermarket and to me I'm
like eating all these Foods I'm like
I've never heard of this in my life but
but they still broadly allow you to
check a lot of these boxes you know yeah
you seem to be very tickled and I don't
know why no two things one just you
your your mention of uh eating a broader
variety of foods one of my favorite Eric
interactions of all time was uh one time
when you came over to work and you just
had this gleam in your eye you said Greg
have you heard about cumin that was that
was one of one of the better starts to a
work day I've ever had I came in like I
um was like a music Insider with my ear
to the ground it was like dude something
just dropped yeah like cumin is out and
and
have you heard of this did you know it
was coming like yeah it'd be like if
somebody dropped a new album and I was
the first person that heard yeah yeah
yeah so that that was uh that was my
first my first thought the first thing I
found a little amusing second thing uh
mentioning that you've been eating
eating more uh Asian Cuisine uh more
like Chinese food more Indian food Etc
uh this is this is
um slightly tangential to health not
exactly what you're talking about but
since we're since this is somewhat a
segment about uh uh difficult to defend
Health claims that people make online uh
one of the one of the ones that just at
its most basic level I find uh
quite quite humorous
um is people claiming that like
vegetarian and vegan diets uh in
particularly diets high in soy and low
in animal products animal fats are just
like catastrophically bad for
Reproductive function
just like look look
at the scoreboard yeah exactly exactly
if if you just if you just pull up a
list of of where are there a lot of
people where does it appear that people
have
been really successfully procreating and
what do they eat yeah um
you know I think that uh
that is observational evidence if
someone wants to throw that back at me
I'll take it on the chin but but like
come on but again come on the claim that
you're making is this eating pattern
tanks fertility right yeah up it doesn't
take that much observational research to
at ver at the very least nullify that
claim correct like yeah if you're
telling me this dietary pattern is
incompatible with fertility
it I don't have to clear a high bar to
disprove that yeah
um yeah so so wrapping things up here
and the reason I bring up the different
Cuisines though is I know there's been a
movement within the uh the dietetics
profession
to just be a little bit more culturally
inclusive because what they kind of
observed like in American dietetics is
that everyone was coming in and a lot of
diet this isn't a knock on dietitians
because they identified that this was a
practice that needed updating but people
were coming in from all different
cultural backgrounds with all different
cooking experiences and Cuisines and
everyone was just being sent home with
like have you tried white potatoes
broccoli and chicken breasts and they're
like
I don't eat this [ __ ] yeah like this is
not
I've never known people that eat this
like this is not how I eat like can you
meet me
not halfway can you meet me an eighth of
the way in the middle here and so like
it is important to kind of just
acknowledge that very very different
cultural traditions and and Cuisines and
things like that they can all be
incorporated in a way that that meets
some of these broad criteria yeah
um you know people will
I can already see comments coming in
thank God as we've covered in previous
episodes I don't read them but you know
wow but what about seed oils being
catastrophic that's an unsupported claim
it just is uh what about gluten causing
all sorts of problems for people who
don't have celiacs disease or
sensitivity of broadly speaking to like
high FODMAP Foods again it's it's an
unsupported kind of line of inquiry that
people have taken mostly to sell books
uh what about carbs being the root of
all cardio metabolic problems they're
just not
um it's not hard to disprove that in a
pretty convincing way uh well Eric you
don't talk about biohacking and fasts
and things like that there's a reason
for that because it's unsupported we're
we're just looking at the distilling
from decades and Decades of nutritional
science what are the things we feel like
we can really hang our hat on here
um what about the plants being poisonous
not going to entertain it it's a silly
idea uh if you really want to make the
claim that eating vegetables is a
potently deleterious Act
you have no value for
research
and and therefore like that conversation
is a non-starter because I'm going to
lean on the research of actual Health
outcomes in humans and if you really
think that eating vegetables is a severe
Hazard To Human Health I I truly don't
know what to tell you yeah uh and again
the the idea that for example
all animal-based protein being unhealthy
that also is an unsupported thing and I
I I'm saying that as as a vegan you know
like I I'm trying to play it just by the
book here looking at the literature I
don't currently eat any animal-based
proteins but I don't have to go around
and say well actually they're absolutely
catastrophic to your health just to make
myself feel better
um you know like I said there is some
evidence to say yeah it might be
worthwhile to limit certainly processed
meats and then you know maybe also like
fatty red meat in moderation right but
the the literature pertaining to poultry
and fish is excellent you know and I
don't have to justify my own biases by
making untrue unsupported Health claims
you know yeah so um yeah just be careful
out there folks there's a lot of stuff
in Nutrition a lot of different dietary
kind of Pockets out there of really uh
really enthusiastic proponents who want
you for some reason to throw out decades
and decades and Decades of incremental
scientific progress and I would at the
at the bare minimum just encourage you
to resist that urge to uh like I said
that that example with the maze maybe
hesitate before saying yeah let me take
me back to the start and I'll just try a
totally different path and forget
everything I learned along the way yeah
um
so you know do we know everything with
nutritional science of course not you
know we don't have enough we don't have
a fully complete picture we cannot draw
up this and say this is the optimal
single human diet like I've said
previously I don't think that even
exists I think that's a bit of a Fool's
errand
um but the stuff isn't that complicated
to the extent that you that you should
say well is it possible that we truly
don't know a single thing about human
nutrition so people will try to over
complicate and you know misattribute
blame to certain nutritional components
they're largely doing that to just open
up a little space a space kind of create
a niche for whatever angle they're
trying to take but what I would
encourage people to do is just focus on
Broad eating patterns try not to focus
on demonizing individual nutrients or
individual food sources and when we look
at the broad eating patterns that are
compatible uh with you know supporting
Health longevity Etc we are starting to
work our way toward a nice uh concise
little list of of patterns and behaviors
that seem to be very compatible with a
healthy diet
yeah one one thing I guess that I would
add is
I so I have
um
I have nothing but disdain for most of
the people who uh who put forth and
promote a lot of these pretty uh pretty
unjustifiable
um perspectives on nutrition
but I I will say that that I and and I
assume both of us have uh quite a bit of
of empathy and understanding for people
who would get sucked in by a lot of that
yeah
um
I I think that there's
you know I think it it makes sense to
look around and say uh especially in in
America uh which is where around half of
our audience is located and I mean a a
pretty disproportionate chunk of the
most out there nutrition folks are are
American and I I uh I think there's
probably a reason for that but I I think
it's it's easy to look around and say
well you know there's
science seems to have improved Our Lives
in so many ways and like Advanced so
much like you know people aren't dying
from communicable diseases at nearly the
rates they were a long time ago
um
like a lot of of medication has improved
like treatment of heart disease uh has
gotten way way better like that kills
way fewer people than it used to
um cancer treatment seems to be
improving on the tech side of things you
know compare computers today to
computers 30 years ago seems like
there's so much progress being made
um but it seems like in spite of a lot
of external markers of progress
um just the General Health of a lot of
people uh
seems to be kind of trending down or
yeah I mean like you you look around and
there's there's a lot of of very
unhealthy people out there
um and it it doesn't seem to comport
part particularly well with the advances
we've seen in in other things
and I think it's easy to look at that
and then look at
um you know some of the some of the
worst excesses of the industrialization
of food production uh all of like the
the hyper palatable hyper processed
foods on the shelves
um and just kind of
kind of
find yourself in a position where
it feels like uh
it feels like something is just is just
wrong with with food like there has to
be something to miss for us to find
ourselves in the position we're in
um you know given the the broader uh
progress we're seeing in you know
basically all other domains like what
what's going on there and so I I think
that
um you know I think that a lot of that
is like very multi-factorial
um but I I think that like single Factor
thinking is very seductive because it
can give you
it can give you a sense of control and
it can give you a feeling that hey if I
can just like control and manage this
one thing like I can I can take control
of my life get everything back on track
um like it's it's in it's a easier
narrative than trying to look at like
all of the different underlying causes
of things going on and the solution
also presents itself as being easier
than you know like hey let let's
completely redesign American cities so
that you can walk and cycle more and be
more active and you know maybe be a
little healthier for for that reason
like let's uh try to transition away
from fossil fuels so air quality is
better so I if you have asthma you can
go outside without hacking up a lung
like you know like the the like big
structural problems are more challenging
to tackle and I I think that by and
large like the American political system
has has proven itself to have little
appetite for tackling a lot of those
things and so
um I don't know like all of it can just
make you feel like you're you're going
crazy and just lose losing control of
your life and when you find yourself in
a situation like that a Silver Bullet
type solution that at least like
purports to have really vast and
Powerful explanatory power starts being
very appealing and seductive
um and so like I I absolutely understand
how
consumers of that information kind of
get sucked down those rabbit holes and
and find it uh convincing or or at least
alluring and placing
um so I I have a ton a ton of empathy
for
for folks who who find themselves in
those content spaces but
um yeah I I just encourage you to uh
I don't know just just take a step back
and look at things a little bit more
critically yeah I know I I totally Echo
that uh I think it's
very understandable to be in a position
where you're ready to embrace some of
those ideas and uh I think it's really
easy nowadays to be exposed to those
ideas in a way that's very very
convincing and compelling
um which I I understand but also just
generally of you to be unfortunate you
know but um yeah I I I certainly don't
fault anyone for getting drawn into some
of those narratives
um and like one of the things that
always comes up along those lines like
you're kind of getting at this with what
you're saying but like I've seen so many
people on the internet who it's like
they have embraced uh a pretty
compelling sales pitch for some very
heterodox like very Fringe nutrition
idea and their response to it is you
know if you say well like look at these
guidelines that are pretty broadly
embraced by like every major health
focused organization
across the world it's not like one
government is just kind of setting the
rules here you know if you bring up that
kind of argument
a lot of times it'll be like
oh yeah great that goes into the dietary
guidelines and look look how far they've
gotten us like the U.S government
dietary guidelines yes and to that I
will also I will often say
who do you know
who doesn't I'm not I'm not talking
about adherence who do you know who can
currently
state
the government dietary guidelines
almost no one in the general population
even knows what they are aside from just
general Vibes which is vegetables are
nice
uh and don't eat as many desserts like
that's pretty much the extent to which
the the general population knows the U.S
dietary guidelines and then ask yourself
of the people who know them who applies
them right and so like the idea that you
can say well here's the guidelines
here's the population level outcomes
looks like the guidelines aren't working
I mean that doesn't it kind of implies
or assumes that people are actually
following those guidelines and all of
the empirical evidence would tell us
that they're not correct you know so
that feeds into a lot of that
conspiratorial thinking of like you had
your chance to set the guidelines and
look how far it's gotten us well the act
of setting a nutritional guideline is
not really the helpful part it's the
adherence to a set of dietary habits and
behaviors and you can make the argument
that perhaps
maybe there would be some utility in
reframing these various eating patterns
in a way that would make adherence more
likely I think that's a very strong case
you could make but the idea that because
obesity rates are high or you know heart
disease type 2 diabetes whatever outcome
you want to focus on because those are
high necessarily the guidelines are
flawed that that if you just interrogate
that argument in and of itself it
doesn't hold up it it fully breaks down
um so yeah I I Echo your sentiment like
I I think it's unfortunate that folks
are making these very superficial
arguments that draw people in I I think
it's unfortunate that some of those
arguments on the surface level do do
seem to be quite compelling and
ultimately I have a lot of empathy for
people who are being led down a road
that is ultimately somewhat deleterious
to their health
um and without really knowing it or sign
signing up for that you know yeah and
then one other thing I just want to
reiterate
there's going to be folks who are like
hey my dietary pattern that I prefer
doesn't really uh mix well with with all
of these criteria that's completely fine
like I I have no like no interest at all
in trying to dictate how people eat
um I just try to put out information
that seems most compatible with the
evidence like there's going to be people
who are really healthy
who say Eric I'm on a ketogenic diet and
I'm you know deviating from several of
these items
but I love the way I eat and all of my
metrics right now would indicate that
I'm in good health if you expect me to
be upset about that you fundamentally
misunderstand my incentives I don't want
people to be in poor health so if you're
in great health and not adhering to all
these guidelines I am genuinely happy
for you uh but the purpose of guidelines
is to say okay if we put 30 million
people on a diet and we had to kind of
give them some check some boxes that
they should strive toward checking these
are the broad brush Strokes you know the
the general guidelines that they ought
to be aiming for based on the evidence
that does not preclude in any way the
possibility that there are people
who deviate from these regularly and are
experiencing really good health at the
moment so
um that that's not the intention I know
a lot of smart folks who are on you know
ketogenic diets that don't check all of
these boxes but are still really well
formulated diets you know like uh I
think a lot of people assume that if
you're on a ketogenic diet you basically
just eat like
uh Philly cheese sandwiches without the
bread all day and that's like all you
eat right uh just beef and cheese and
and and that's it
um I know a lot of folks who are you
know on ketogenic diets they eat a lot
of fibrous vegetables they have some
nuts and seeds in the mix like they
actually do check more of these boxes
than you might think so so I don't want
this to be the type of thing that uh
becomes like a diet Wars like I don't
want to put gasoline on that flame and
fuel more of it
um but what I would encourage people to
do is if you have a dietary pattern that
you really like but perhaps you are
unsatisfied with your current health
status or you have some concerns about
um you know your current diets
compatibility with some of these
guidelines you don't necessarily have to
overhaul every behavior in your life and
immediately start from scratch you might
just consider saying okay I'm gonna work
toward getting a couple of these
additional guidelines met within the
broad uh eating pattern that I current
only have okay so the purpose here is to
be helpful and to lead people toward
evidence-based guidelines not to
disparage any particular dietary
strategy or to make people uh angry
because their preferred method of
dieting doesn't you know check every box